hello and welcome to zero playing
Chandra I cannot pronounce that program
that properly okay so no name in down I
don't have a good score there one out of
three I wanted to go for the bangko but
he didn't allow that yeah he if I was
supposed to be okay for black I don't
know that line to be honest okay so
let's try it anyway what do you play 36
looks like a strange strange kind of
specially cough type of position but
we'll see what happens i think Bishop g5
looks quite awkward so I'm going to okay
now probably a three before Bishop a
three heads still plays Bishop entering
slightly surprised about that doesn't
look too threatening maybe quinter in
five four look at the age let's do that
I don't think you can take the six that
would be a very um strange self pen okay
yeah it didn't go for that would have
been surprising okay yeah I thought I'd
just take let's do it o Queen takes I
didn't expect Queen takes hmm why is
that good pawn takes Knight your voice
down right good for black I think
threatening on each one on c2 so he has
to take with the bishop but
then 94 looks pretty good I can play 94
no matter what basically threatening
night c 2 and on d 2 so i can pre move
94 here i have impaired and play that
anyway seems like i'm winning stuff so
double attacks i'm winning the exchange
it's still not easy because the pieces
that he has they're all good no wonder i
wonder about this may be here at Bishop
to c6 it's not easy it's not easy to win
and to play b5 is probably questionable
likessee takes 8 x 95 yeah it's one of
those cases where white definitely they
are blundered into that exchange loss
but it's not a clear affair at all ok
wants to go 95 I know it did it this is
a tough tough kind of decision but I
think I want to get rid of that night
and here I have an idea i can try to
reroute the bishop over to be 62 c 5
this could be um this could help still
not an easy win
now if I go back in they probably will
play Bishop e3 let's bring the King
somewhat near okay i wonder if i should
go 85 here in this position and simply
block everything then the bishop over to
c5 it will be difficult to open up the
position quite clearly as I try I try
this first yeah i was thinking here c5
is possible that i'm not sure about it
yeah now he threatens to cheek and play
discoveries no yeah not easy at all
absolutely not
and now be five actually would have been
an idea ok I have to do this I think so
I bishop is crawling over here to see
five
yeah it's it's as I said multiple times
not an easy win at all can maybe take
take e5 it's how to do without this
yeah check yeah the thing is it's easier
for white to play this position it's
just it's just what it is time warning
he is going to go e 6 those games are
always somewhat tough to show my Gayo
they just blunder and it's not easy to
to convert at all been using is pretty
unnecessary but it wasn't a simple win
after the exchange got blundered really
wasn't that's unfortunately there is not
very easy yeah so it's a bit of a bit of
a tough thing yeah so here I mean it's
the exchange but it's not not easy man
from a technical point of view I think I
missed one clear chance this is okay I
think they're missed one very clear
opportunity I could have played be five
in this position and I think this is
probably the the key moment I simply saw
that too late because here I'm going to
get a far better situation on the
queenside I think here should probably
be able to win this and with the bishop
coming here it's still difficult to win
I mean but this is better than what I
played again before
yeah this is even clearer now and here
it gets to a situation okay I shouldn't
lose but maybe have six but this is
still ok I think maybe I just have to
improve around here and just let him
take men I wanted to still preserve some
winning chances if I let him take only
five maybe I simply have to be quite
modest down now I cannot I cannot win
this anymore that's definitely out of
the picture we stopped fish still
believes I'm winning but how how are you
winning and here this is just just the
wrong idea i guess this is what the
engine wants to do keep things yeah
maybe at five instead Jeff that's still
difficult yeah yes so this is also it's
fine it's far easier for white to play
this is a pse 45 it's super obvious what
he has to do its it just it just it's
difficult can you do it I missed b5 this
is the this is the thing that costs me
the game ultimately if I just play a b5
at the right moment here I am I was here
this is clear and here next move even
more on here b5 is some leading to a
pretty good position because I can get
rid of those weaknesses and my rooks get
get to play yeah here in something
something like that um I just I just
can't use my rooks later still still
work but clearly blacks favor here
um afterwards got very difficult to play
okay well thanks for watching